open question because there are lots of
different answers to this at least I
hope there are you go to the shops to
buy something you go to shops to buy
something
ok how can you pay money be more
specific I can one of the type hands up
let's good talk a debit card debit card
number one not pitch change good
so pair another gift cards excellent
does a bank that cheeseburger be two
dollars cuz I pay by a bank line ok so
actually we'll get so we'll get two
loans only another one someone else
residents a damn thing check if you are
living in the nineties by check what do
you say Lucas savings ok so that would
be ok so applause so I what does get
push stand for it let's get this get
electronic and I heard up the front
funds transfer its transfer right
transfer from you to the guy you're paid
at point of sale right so you can just
be right there at the checkout and it
works the case to pay reward okay put on
sorry I was I'm getting a bit ahead
myself I said f+ applies to a bunch of
being late on but stood there for a
second I'm getting a lot of good answers
but now that is quite a few on the board
a lot of the ones that you're saying to
me are either already on the board or
they're actually not forms of payment
I'll give you an example okay lay by
lay by is not a form of payment in fact
it's a form of not payment right it's a
I won't pay for this and we agree on
conditions on how that's going to work
out in the future
right okay so before you raise your hand
and shout out a few more now that we
have a few more on the board think about
where am I fit I'll give you an example
further and what it's already on the
board is points points
where do you think points like critical
points like okay what do you think it
fits on here and I'll give it clue it's
not credit it would almost certainly be
gift cards and tell you why I'll show
you one right now if you've got a credit
card right and you're earning points in
before that kind of thing right where
you go they're actually very small bugs
when you go to cash in your thousands of
points to get a value out of that
what they'll give you is a gift card
right and then you can use that which is
like well actually I have
I've still got $7 on it that's also
that's okay Oh are there any others that
really you thought about it they're not
on the list
yeah hey puss okay hold on hey pass pay
pass on pay wave same kind of idea right
it's really just a form of this
it's a dip it's a ditch it's still a way
of pain but it's just that of the chip
is different yeah that's right so it's
the physical scanning methods different
okay but it really is any of these right
it's a pretty good list are you guys
happy with that list um you know
nowadays there like I said if you're
living in the 90s you pay by cheque
increasingly you cannot pay by cheque
anymore okay um you can't always pay by
the next most kind of probably is credit
but you can't always pay by credit some
places there you'll go there and they'll
have a sign that talks about credit
cards and it says something any
suggestions anyone read these signs
before have you paid attention when you
get in a shop yet
okay so firstly they might just say
forget it if you want to buy a cab at me
you give you cash again I don't take
credit cards okay the other thing they
might say is they they take credit but
they say but okay number one you know
they might say yeah motox I'll get I'll
get into the reason why you got an okay
ah I had another one um they'll say
they'll say a quantity and the quantity
varies it's 5 or 10 or 20 or whatever
right but they say look if you gonna buy
something small I would accept your
credit card I'll only accept cash or
debit right now hold on this is really
interesting it's give me different
quantities right oh why is this they've
got the machine sitting there like a
little F possum
reader things right why would they apply
a little bit of some kind to it could
wait oh okay since the coerce people to
buy more objective case is the business
women at the front okay something you
said tax I'll put that off on this side
for you I wanna hear what's appears you
said you gonna say that okay let me
explain let me explain okay um American
Express why is there are why is there
what's the no he for discrimination
against one kind of credit card versus
what are yellow are the bad ones it used
to be common that you get diners club
but they're they're very they're very
uncommon these days these three day the
big guys and their international yeah
ah okay now it has to do with something
called a surcharge I put this in another
hello
yeah you might if you're on the other
side of the business you might you may
owe is such what's a surcharge
it's a it's an extra little fee right so
here's the idea let's let's let's change
our position now I asked you about all
of this in terms of your pain okay um
now let's put you on the other side of
the counter someone comes to you you're
a vendor down right and they want to pay
you with these methods okay now here's
the thing right to set cash doesn't cost
you anything right like if I put five
dollars in your hand there's no like you
get the five dollars all of it right but
to do credit or debit cards right like
we were talking about that machine right
that machine it costs money number one
you gotta buy the Machine number two you
often actually have to pay ongoing fees
to keep using it right some of you
noticed like um some of them they're
actually wireless like they don't this
they can just take it around anywhere
it's it's working just like a phone it's
got reception and it dials up and it
talks to the bank and does all of this F
posh stuff right it's not free there are
guys over here that will charge you for
that okay now in particular American
Express is renowned because they charge
the motors right so if you're a little
guy and like as a shop you don't get a
lot of business why would you bother
paying these guys right lots and lots of
money every month or every quarter
whatever just show you that you can get
the AMEX people right they've probably
got some other card in their wallet
anyway or cash so you say no forget it
I'm not gonna pay them alternatively you
know even when you do these guys which
are a little better this still costs
involved okay and that's why they'll
apply minimum to coerce you to buy more
so that for you as a vendor yeah it's
worth your while all right yeah
Coleman yeah it's pretty : yeah like
it's um I I would put American press
Visa and MasterCard I put them all in
the same level like it's not like this
is a little guy but because of this
surcharge business
this is them this is their business
model this is how you wonder how did
credit card businesses make money they
make it they didn't make it off you they
make it off businesses by charging them
okay all right now here's the thing
again
quick question alone whoever was it's
exactly like a phone call exactly like I
think what that was but let's move on
okay now everyone is that okay if you
got if it's the rather than after you
can come back to okay now again I'm
putting you in the shoes of the business
again okay
now let's suppose you really really want
to be able to provide credit okay but
it's costing you money okay you won't be
able to be able to pay credit to you but
you've got to rent these so these
devices you don't pay these guys so
here's what you do okay yeah from CBA or
whatever by the way CBA a Westpac E&Z
etcetera they're not the credit card
providers these guys are okay that's a
sign here's what you do suppose one day
you didn't have the credit card machine
you going buy one you go on rent one
right so cost you money they're not
cheap so here's what you do why don't we
have before we have like a soft drink or
something right we had like 500 mil
bottles one liter voila Toledo bought
and they had some costs right remember
so much sense it's like a dollar 20 okay
so here's what you do remember the cost
for you as a business to be able to
assess credit right it's not just the
once off its gonna keep going
right so you're making the same amount
of money but you're getting less profits
cuz you got to pay these other guys so
here's your solution
he's your solution you take all of your
things right and you just add a little
bit to each one you make them all a
little more expensive something like
this
maybe you push this up too many cents
maybe a dollar fifty maybe 275 something
like this okay so this is your way of
compensating your like this is an extra
charge I'm gonna pay for but I still ask
to God you know feed the family and all
that kind of thing so I can't my bottom
line my profits what I take home and I
can spend I'll need to raise these
prices to sort of compensate for this
okay this is really interesting because
now if you come in and you're like hey
you've raised your prices right but
maybe you didn't even have actually
probably most of you don't have credit
cards right cuz you gotta have like
income and that kind of thing people are
just hand them out so you're like I pay
cash all the time this is not fair I'm
getting ripped off because other people
want to use credit other people use
credit so businesses they recognize this
and that's why they do things like this
it recognizes this is this is the good
guys this is the action and it says pay
less pay cash what's that about what
does that means anyone actually done
this before yeah okay so what happened
wasn't me so this is a simple concept
right but why is that it's not to do
with GST it has to do with this
difference if you're paying cash the
business in a sense it doesn't have to
you don't have to foot the bill for all
of this stuff right so they're willing
to pay you this lower price sorry you're
willing to let you pay the lower price
right versus this higher price which
you'll pay for F pause okay this makes
sense
so this pay less pay cash business it
has to do with this it's really quite
interesting